okay i might be playing magnus but i
don't know so i'm recording
um the rating kind of matches
it's probably not magnus
but it might be
okay already not a great position
up a piece
you
oh no
okay we're playing we're playing a match
uh is this actually magnus
alexa quiet
uh i have no idea of the audio is
working but hopefully it is
i have corn cooking hope it doesn't burn
that was my timer for the corn
uh let's take this
i don't think this is magnus opponents
not playing like
so world champion like
oh no i'm still alive
take that
okay
oh i'm not playing madness i'm just
playing an admirer of magnus
ah okay i'll play one more
and i have to not burn the corn
um
uh i thought i was maybe playing magnus
very disguised username
man i really thought there was a
possibility i'd be playing magnus
i guess i should have checked the
profile sooner
um
now do i post this on youtube and
clickbait oh oh no
wait do i take no i can push
okay let's try and win the game i feel
more confident now that i know i'm not
playing magnus
um i'm still worse though
open file
this is a threat oh this is also hanging
play this move
okay i'm gonna try and set up the still
me trap
seven seconds not much time
this is a sad position
i'm so sad okay um thank you
for the game let's see how many people
in the chat will
uh something something
anyway um if you're just joining wait
i'm not streaming but um
uh
i'll probably put that on youtube
yeah i'll probably put that on youtube
okay i have to run and make sure the
corn doesn't burn